is there
oh okay that's nice everybody enjoying
their meal
hey babe yeah how about we take the beer
sign down until our guests leave and
then we can discuss it no no
I'm gonna leave it up I think it ties
the whole room together
okay
Jack thinks Hunter's very talented
you know what
I don't think he's that good at least
he's an artist BFG I'm a screenwriter
and I'm a Candle Maker but you don't
hear me prank
no all you do is you get me to try to
work on my rich friends for an
investment opportunity man I would love
to burn your candles you burn it you buy
it oh good I'll be your first customer
you're hardly by first
don't go see yourself
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
politicians are always coming around
telling us they're going to fix our
schools promising this and that
but you Mr Scott
you were actually doing it you have
taught these kids with hard work that
anything is possible
you are a Dream Maker and I thank you
I thank you ah thank you I thank you I
thank you
there were a lot of times over the years
whereas pressure to get into the drug
game but always thought back to my
guardian angel
gift that you gave
so I just want to thank you forgive me
the opportunity to go to college educate
myself and be and be the next president
Obama
[Applause]
hey I thought you weren't supposed to
eat anything for a couple of hours after
you've had a crown put in
having this new kind of quick drying
bonding
sounds like a good dentist oh yeah
yeah what's his name
crentist
your dentist name is crentist
huh
sounds a lot like dentist
maybe that's why he became a dentist
your teeth
let me see him let me see him
oh
oh
you should floss them I'm a magical
fairy who floated into your office to
bring a little bit of magic into your
lives to give you all raises and we are
grateful but here's the thing the thing
about Tinkerbell gym everyone has to
believe in her
damn she dies she dies
now who here
believes in Tinkerbell let's see it show
up hands I do
huh
come on everyone all right guys stop I
already spent the money hi
come on Jim you're killing her We
believe
We Believe
oh look at this wonderful recognition of
Nellie's leadership I believe
staying alive staying alive
stay alive
um by the way how I use my walk I'm a
woman's man no time to talk what is it
loud women more have been kicked around
since I was born when it's all right
it's okay you can't live the other way
okay you didn't maintain 100 beats per
minute and the ambulance didn't arrive
because nobody called 9-1-1 so you lost
them okay he's dead anyone know what we
do next anybody Rose I have no idea
anyone else we bury him wrong and check
for an organ donor card if he has one we
only have minutes to harvest he has no
wallet I checked he is an organ donor he
is yeah give me some ice in a styrofoam
bucket
here we go
we search for the organs where's the
heart the brush the precious heart I'm
not feeling well I need to sit down
family are you okay
oh my God
oh my God this is getting more and more
delicious wait a minute
it's go time
hey Nelly I mean
I made some soup well I don't want any
soup but it's really good oh come on
Andy
ah
Andy we wanted to talk to you a lot of
us are very concerned about you you're
dirty you stinky booze you're limping
inexplicably I just want you guys not to
worry because all Annie's gonna be just
fine no no see this is what we're
talking about
I mean what was that accent and last
time I checked you were drunk now you're
not drunk
why you just Dive Right In
you know around age 12 I just started
going for it
[Music]
what what happened
I fell off the toilet
I'm caught between the toilet and the
wall
what do you need no not you
someone else get paid I think Pam's
going to want to come into the men's
room you're right
oh he needs to lift me
and they need to clean me up a little
bit bring a wet towel
Ryan is uh dead no he's not Dad I just
saw him no
okay can you just get up yourself I
he only grilled your foot yeah forget it
I'll just get out myself
oh oh God how have you decided
you all had the linguine red sauce on
the side
the sauce does not come on the side I
will send it back
I want garlic bread toasted not burnt if
it comes burnt I will send it back okay
then
and for you sir I will have the gabagool
hello what
the Gabba ghoul
I don't really know what that is
I don't I don't I don't have to have
what he's trying to say is God bless
Google
I will have the spaghetti with a side
salad okay
if the salad is on top I send it back
and this next award is going out to our
own little Pam Beasley I think we all
know what a war Pam is going to be
getting this year it is the whitest
sneakers award because she always has
the whitest tennis shoes on
yeah
easily ladies and gentlemen oh here we
go
[Music]
okay first off my kids because I
couldn't have done it without them
let's give Michael a round of applause
for emceeing tonight because
it's a lot harder
and also because of Dwight too
um so
finally I want to thank God
because God gave me this Dundee
and I feel God in this Chili's tonight
thank you
[Laughter]
Joanna's as good as rescued where do you
suppose all the wig makers of London go
to obtain their human hair to you
so you think
[Music]